[Music]
the first shot went into arms i believe
it was a 90 year old grandmother in the
united kingdom on december 8th
and then you know a week later a nurse
in new york becomes the first american
person to get vaccinated
we'd been dealing with a pandemic for
almost a year at this point and it
really felt like this kind of
moment where
you know holy crap like this might
actually be the beginning of the end of
that
and i don't think any of us realized at
that point
just how
long of a road it would be
from there
covett has been resurging even in places
where they thought they had it nailed
down this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
it was a desperate situation in india
rich and poor alike they were all
equally hit there are a lot of mistruths
out there about the vaccines you've seen
the pictures all over the internet of
people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized
most of the vaccines were booked by the
rich nations many of the african leaders
later called it
vaccinapathide
over the past year the world has been
engaged in a massive effort to end the
covert 19 pandemic
but a series of daunting and
unpredictable challenges have stood in
the way
to understand how far we've come and
where we could go from here you have to
trace the course of the vaccination
campaign across the globe country by
country city by city shot by shot
this is humanity's first year of
fighting back against covet 19.
[Music]
as the vaccines were becoming available
we realized that this was going to be an
unprecedented public health campaign
globally
never before had we had a vaccine that
we tried to roll out simultaneously all
across the world
and we started to realize that there was
not going to be the kind of
data tracking that everybody would want
[Music]
during the pandemic in 2020 there was
very poor availability of data tracking
the actual cases of this disease
public health organizations were not
doing a sufficient job of tracking case
numbers hospitalizations deaths and we
realized that nobody was really setting
up to do that for vaccinations so we
decided that we needed to step in and
tackle that ourselves
this is bloomberg's covid 19 vaccine
tracker where we tracked vaccinations of
the largest vaccination campaign in
history
we put together a team of people and
decided that you know we would just
start counting and trying to figure out
where were vaccines going
at the very beginning everybody was
basically just trying to get shots at
arms as fast as possible
the drug companies that were making
these vaccines they had really just
begun production they hadn't nailed down
their you know supply process just yet
and we were really just in this this
period of not enough vaccines or even
close to it to meet what the demand was
and so people were desperate for this
stuff
today we're on the verge of another
american medical miracle together we
will defeat the virus and we will soon
end the pandemic and we will save
millions and millions of lives
hundreds of thousands of lives
in the united states
and around the world
would be saved which people would still
be alive today
if our government
had listened to the science had told
americans the real risk of this virus
and put tools and information and clear
messaging out to help people save their
lives and protect themselves from
getting this virus
as the u.s vaccine rollout ramps up
major logistical issues start to emerge
the process the trump administration had
set up
was sending vaccines to states
um and they were they were sending
um kind of an unpredictable number it
was far short of what the states wanted
governors were screaming uh you know we
were trying to get the basic information
out of the system
but there was no tracking system for
vaccines
we don't have good tools for tracking
data around covid generally a lot of the
data collection that's done is done by
cdc
cdc's culture is very retrospective
they're accustomed to doing these very
careful analyses that are backward
looking they're based on retrospective
data so data they collect after the fact
it's not the kind of organization that
has sort of a crisis mentality that you
need to put out data even if it's not
fully baked
so this is the the shared spreadsheet
for bloomberg's vaccine tracker that we
would enter every day with a 175
countries
all the u.s states and canadian
provinces and the data was coming from
all over all sorts of different places
from social media to reporters hounding
government sources to you know a
lieutenant governor who wanted to post
it on twitter every week this normally
is not something that journalists should
have to do this is data that's normally
tracked by governments and produced in a
kind of uniform way but we have never
had a situation like this where
real time information was required to
respond to the pandemic
as more supply becomes available in the
first weeks of 2021 the u.s soon hits an
encouraging number
more doses of vaccine administered than
total coronavirus cases to date
i remember we crossed this milestone
early on and i felt like this really
helpful moment and then you realize like
oh my god there's still so much further
to go
but in other parts of the world the
vaccination campaign has barely even
started
brazil
was starting to see a second wave that
started kind of in early
mid-december in the northern city of
manaus which turned out to be one of the
great tragedies of the pandemic in
brazil
bolsonaro our president
has been consistent in his approach to
the pandemic in that he has mostly
dismissed it
he does not believe in vaccines he just
thinks people get better immunity when
they get sick and recover
and so his government was very late in
buying vaccines
we had a senate probe into the
government's handling of the pandemic
this year that looked at all the
attempts that were made by pfizer for
example in selling vaccines to brazil
and they emailed and they sent letters
and they offered and they called for
meetings and the government would just
not respond
pressure built on the government enough
that they had to buy vaccines but we
took so long to buy the vaccines that
once they decided to buy the answer we
got from companies is well from july on
i can give you the shots you want but i
don't have them right now because i
already sold them
brazil's limited supply of vaccines
barely makes a dent in infection rates
allowing the pandemic to rage on almost
unabated for months
when it comes to buying vaccines
you have to rush a lot of the countries
that waited
ended up having to wait longer to get
the shots
in terms of vaccination at the beginning
of the year there were no prospects as
yet on supply of the vaccines to to
africa and what was available was being
booked by the rich nations
so there was a concern that the poor
nations or low-income nations would not
get access to these vaccines at all
so kovacs was a deliberate
initiative to really ensure that there
was access to the kovind 19 vaccines
equitably among nations
kovacs founded by the who and other
global health organizations in 2020 sets
an ambitious goal for 2021
deliver nearly 2 billion vaccine doses
to low-income countries by the end of
the year
it's so important to try and get these
products into every country and every
environment
to stop this this crisis save lives as
rapidly as possible it's impossible that
the global economy going again unless
all countries are vaccinating it's
impossible to protect against the
emergence of variants if we are only
vaccinating in some parts of the world
key to kovacs's supply is a country long
known as one of the world's
pharmaceutical powerhouses
india of course is known as the pharmacy
to the world because it produces the
vast majority of the world's vaccines in
fact much of that is located just in one
institute the serum institute of india
on the outskirts of the city of mumbai
the serum institute had got a license to
mass-produce doses of the astrazeneca
vaccine
and it had agreed to actually export
this to the kovacs initiative
and kovacs was of course counting on
india to make good on these promises
going into 2021 the mood in india was
one of jubilation india was reporting
less than 10 000 cases or roughly around
that level
prime minister modi went before the
world economic forum in davos and
actually said that india had beaten the
corona virus
did both scientists and policymakers
know that a more potent strain of the
coronavirus what we initially knew as
b1617 was brewing within the indian
population
so in april in the u.s there was this
real shift in
vaccinations where all of a sudden
supply was getting a lot more plentiful
and there was a real sense that you know
we're really going to be turning this
corner
at that same time we also began to see
you know that there were people out
there who were not interested in being
vaccinated cobin 19 vaccines can help
save lives but many people are still
hesitant to get that jab it wasn't that
long ago that all we were talking about
was how hard it is to get a covet 19
vaccination appointment now take a look
around me see all these empty chairs if
you're like 21 years old and you say to
me should i get vaccinated i go no
yeah getting people truthful information
about the vaccines was
one of the most critical things we could
do
unfortunately
there are a lot of mistruths out there
more people are dying from the covet
vaccine than from coving there's been
people who've long suspected that there
was some sort of an interface between
what's being injected in these shots and
all of the 5g towers
i think we didn't do a good enough job
early on communicating to the public we
didn't have public health agencies
speaking about the vaccine trying to
encourage consumers to go out and get
vaccinated when they could get access to
the vaccine and that was a mistake we
sort of
seeded the information marketplace to
people who were putting out a counter
message
one of the things that we began to
notice when we really began to look at
vaccination data in the u.s in detail
was that there was this
significant split emerging and so you
can see on this county level map here
where red and orange places have really
low rates of vaccination
if you take a look at these places in
orange and red like the mountain west
down here in louisiana arkansas and
mississippi places in florida and
michigan a lot of those places are the
same places that have been very very
hard hit by the delta variant
levels of vaccine hesitancy remain
relatively high in the us
but the phenomenon starts to show up in
other countries as well
an example of that globally
is with china and russia
china and russia very early on made the
decision that they were going to start
administering their vaccines well before
they had been fully tested
the lasting effect of that decision
is that it really shook everyone's
confidence in those vaccines both the
people in china and russia and also the
people who were contracted to buy their
vaccines
you can see the results particularly in
russia a lot of the russian people are
still very suspicious of the russian
sputnik vaccine
in particular
would be
in some ways it's unfortunate because
overall there are safe and effective
vaccines uh just like a lot of the
western vaccines but these are the kinds
of decisions that public health
officials have to make in a tough
situation and sometimes there's no right
answer
meanwhile another crisis is brewing the
rise of a devastating new variant
delta really reared its head in india
around march april 2021 that was when we
saw the numbers increasing everyone
thought we'd
but beyond the worst of the coronavirus
what officials in india call a tsunami
of coronavirus cases nearly one million
in the last three days alone
now the indian healthcare system on the
best of days is inadequate when delta
started flaring up in india what we saw
is that hospitals were so overflowing
that even the richest couldn't access
healthcare we don't have anything
available
and patients are dying hospitals were
running out of basic supplies like
oxygen
we saw crematoriums overflowing
it was a desperate situation in india
with delta ripping through its
population india is forced to make a
decision with global consequences
the syrian institute of india ended up
having to
re-direct much of its supply to its own
domestic needs
we saw india discontinue exports to
kovacs and that really meant that
african countries at that time did not
have anywhere else to turn
midway through the year kovacs has only
distributed 88 million doses far short
of its original goal of 1.8 billion by
the end of the year
we did an analysis of the gap between
wealthy countries and the poorest
countries and their access to these
vaccines and we found that
the wealthiest countries were getting
vaccinated at a rate that was uh 25
times faster than the poorest countries
in the poorest countries they're still
struggling to to get basic levels of
vaccination
and the countries are suffering for it
every time vaccines came supplies would
be over in just a matter of hours
i remember when i tried to go get my
first shot for the estradica vaccine
i waited a whole day in in a queue and i
could not get it so i only managed to
get my first shot after queueing for
days
it really showed
how big the divide is
the vaccine campaign in the united
states kind of hit its low point in
july 2021
and that is largely because things were
going really well at that point it was
summertime we celebrated july 4th as
kind of like a turning point
but very swiftly after that
came the delta mutation
the delta mutation the vaccine is less
effective against it
it still keeps people out of the
hospitals and prevents a lot of deaths
but people started getting and spreading
and transmitting the virus more and more
the delta variant in fact already
sending unvaccinated americans to the
hospital in alarming numbers our
inpatient units are at capacity
and so
people have to
either get better enough to go home
or if they succumb to their illnesses
and die that opens up a bed
the delta variant because it is so
contagious does a unfortunately a very
good job finding people who haven't yet
been vaccinated
nurses are not only tired but in short
supply
we have a very low vaccination rate in
our community here in idaho
and nobody's masked
and people are like yeah
it's all open it's all free and it's
devastating to me will the vaccine save
them now
no
but you could have done that before
soon after delta's arrival in the u.s
evidence starts to emerge that the
vaccine's efficacy is waning over time
the problem is first identified in
israel one of the world's leaders in
vaccine administration and data tracking
you had israel collecting more
systematic data and they were the first
to pick that up cdc actually dismissed
the israeli data when it first emerged
in the summer
cdc is probably going to do a really
good analysis of that and tell us
exactly how many breakthrough infections
occurred
six months later but it doesn't help
inform decisions that have to get made
in real time like should we be
administering boosters to high risk
populations
the news is not as bleak in other parts
of the world
india's infection rate having peaked in
may continues to plummet as the
country's vaccination program finally
gathers steam vaccinations increased
sevenfold from april to august
[Music]
in brazil whose anemic early campaign
costs hundreds of thousands of lives a
stunning turnaround is underway
in june july you really started uh
seeing more of a pickup and in july that
coincides with when we started getting
more pfizer shots at hand
and when governments started broadening
groups that were eligible for vaccine
brazil's rate of first doses
administered soon surpasses that of the
us
relatively low levels of vaccine
hesitancy help make this possible the
country's world-class national health
care system also plays a decisive role
it would have been much much worse
without this public health care system
which is
everywhere brazil's huge country
they have more than 30 000
posts spread across the country so you
will see pictures of healthcare workers
giving vaccines in canoes in the amazon
you know and it really is everywhere
yes we took much longer than needed to
actually start vaccinating
but right now it is a success story of
brazil's vaccination campaign
despite also not a railing against
vaccines to this day
[Music]
we are just
now preaching to people and we are
praying for people
because there is no job and people have
become but now they are resorting to
faith
their vaccination rates in africa are
still low
around november we were still looking at
around six percent
the coronavirus has taken a huge
economic toll
that has already
taken back some of the gains
that we achieved as far as poverty
reduction
so there is a huge social and financial
toll that this pandemic has put on
africa
for many african governments it was
a rude awakening of being dependent on
others
for basics
so we have seen several african leaders
announce plans to set up
vaccination plants
south africa senegal rwanda uganda kenya
all announced plans to either expand or
actually start new vaccination plans
they want to be prepared for the future
so that
in case of
say another pandemic
then you will not really be slowly
relying on vaccines from outside
it's been a rude awakening for for the
africans to
to to shape up for the future
[Music]
as 2021 comes to an end the threat of
covert 19 is far from extinguished
even as many countries have achieved
high vaccination rates others lag far
behind
and a new variant of unknown potency has
started to spread omicrom is already
labeled a variant of concern meaning it
could be more transmissible and possibly
more virulent
i think one of the challenges of dealing
with the sars cov2 virus is that you
know it always takes
several weeks to really get the answers
that you need
i don't think we know yet what the
future is with omicron and hopefully we
will in the coming days and weeks but i
think uncertainty is probably
the core story of this pandemic and
having to make decision after decision
without
all of the information that you need
[Music]
this pandemic has
really highlighted a lot of the problems
with the global public health system
but i think it's also important to take
a step back and look at what just
happened
a year after the first shots went into
arms eight billion shots have been
administered that is a stunning number
we have vaccine campaigns in every
country in the world
that didn't happen with polio it didn't
happen with a smallpox vaccine it didn't
happen with
you know aids medications
for all of those it took decades
how long this pandemic persists depends
to the largest degree on how we use the
knowledge we've gained so far and the
tools that are becoming available in
terms of vaccines tests and treatments
we could have this pandemic well under
control and be coming out the other side
of it within six months or it could take
over a year we've got to make sure that
the tools that we have available are
equitably distributed around the world
so that we can reduce the risk of
variant emergence as we bring down the
burden of disease and of course get
economies functioning again
[Music]